[Music]  tell me something why is it so hard for  you to kill this man  he knew every move of mine before I made  it  I have them right there take the shot  and he'd be gone like a ghost do you  really wanna live forever  who is he  [Music]  I think I know why is as good as you  he is you 25 years ago they made you  from me they chose me because there's  never been anybody like me we have to  end this right now  you have all of his gifts without his  painting  you made a person out of another person  then you sent me to kill him  he made a choice to do this to me  this thing - you're struggling with it's  fear  embrace them and then overcome it  of all the people in the world to come  after me why would he send you  you